architecture school was everything i
dreamed of i met new people we came up
with crazy ideas i traveled and saw
buildings all over the world and i'd say
it was one of the most wonderful times
of my life until reality hit
in this video i'm going to talk about
how i paid it all back in two years on
an interns salary this video is
sponsored by planetree with hp we're
going to talk about how they're helping
jane's institute to stop deforestation
later on in this video hey guys my name
is dammy and i'm an architect in
beautiful vancouver bc now some of you
are going to graduate with a lot more
than 50 000 in debt and some of you will
graduate with a lot less but whatever
the amount student loans suck
and it's this black cloud that's
constantly looming over your head if you
don't want to be paying thousands of
dollars in interest it's best if you pay
it back asap but when i was in school i
was not that financially savvy i
realized how much money i was paying in
interest
for example in canada right now the
student loans interest rate on a fixed
rate is five point two percent i mean
five point two percent out of fifty
thousand dollars that's only like twenty
six hundred dollars right
so you idiot
it's five point two percent for every
year you're paying back your student
loans so if you're paying it back over
ten years that's around 11
dollars
what was actually worse was realizing
that the government had actually given
me more money than i needed because i
was moving out of province by myself
which i used on booze food partying and
3d printers that actually made me
realize a dark twisted secret the most
important thing about the school you
pick if you're paying for your own
school is not the professors the courses
the projects or the reputation but it's
the cost there's a massive cost
difference between different schools and
you might think that going to an
expensive school is going to give you a
better job and a better pay
but think again
because all interns salary is actually
in a very similar range of mediocre so
when you graduate with a
two hundred thousand dollar debt versus
a ten thousand dollar debt you're
actually significantly reducing your
income paying a thousand dollars is very
different from five hundred dollars when
you're just starting out luckily i
figured this out before i started my
masters so two of my top criteria was
cost and the speed at which i could get
my degree
because one or two extra years that
makes a huge difference in your debt
and the potential income you could be
having by working so i went back to
ryerson which is where i went for my be
arc because they gave me an awesome
scholarship and they had a fast track
program which let me graduate and one
and a half years compared to two to
three or even three and a half years
from some other programs throughout my
master's i work part-time as a teaching
assistant if you can try your best to
get a job at the architecture school
because it's very convenient and they
pay quite well thanks to my smart moves
i graduated with only
50 000
in student loans but it wasn't until i
graduated that the gravity of my loans
really started to kick in and that year
i probably entered one of the lowest
points in my life fifty thousand dollars
was just a massive amount for me and i
felt constantly overwhelmed with the
idea of having to pay it back especially
on my tiny tiny tiny intern salary it
didn't help that all my friends were
working while i was in school they were
all making more money than me i'm never
going to forget that one day when i told
them how much money i made
they all
were shocked because you know they
thought that i have a bachelor's and a
master's and they thought that i would
be making way more money
and this put me in an even worse
downward spiral i had no motivation i
wasn't enjoying my work and i was
becoming resentful of everyone and of
myself let me just pause for a quick
moment for a message from our sponsor hp
as an architect i spend a lot of time
reading the fine print on the
environmental impact of some of the
products and materials i'm specifying i
try to look at the material content and
where it comes from but also the
company's manufacturing process or the
recycling program hp is a company that's
actually making a lot of strides on
their sustainability agenda not just
using it as a marketing pitch so their
newest initiative is a partnership with
trees for jane which is an international
grassroots campaign with the goal of
stopping deforestation and helping
communities around the world and so all
of your hp purchases from now through
june is going to contribute to planting
1 million trees if you've never heard of
dr jane goodall she's the founder of the
jane goodall institute and she's also a
un messenger of peace
and the foundation's been doing some
really amazing things including their
goal to plant one million trees by the
end of 2022. hp's products and their
packaging contain recycled material like
their hp envy 7955e
which is made with 45 recycled plastic
their products also contain ocean bound
plastics
they also have a recycling program where
you can send back your empty cartridges
and they'll recycle it for you so you
know it's going to the right places
anyways all of your hp purchases from
now through june is going to contribute
to this initiative so
if you need to buy any printers or
products this is probably a good time to
buy so anyways back to my story there
was one thing that really helped me out
of this downward spiral and that was
making a plan so first i sat down and
analyzed my debt
and i set an ideal payoff date for me
that ideal timeline was two years
because that was the time that i set for
myself to get my architect's license so
it was actually kind of easy for me to
visualize myself in this new life newly
licensed architect with no debt then i
used an online calculator like this one
where you can adjust the time span and
it's going to tell you how much you need
to pay each month to pay it off by that
day from this i got my number i then
scheduled in my diary to check in with
myself every week to make sure that i
was on track once i set that goal
it became very obvious that i had to do
two things
i had to seriously increase my income
and i had to seriously reduce my
spending i started packing my lunch i
stopped eating out i cut my inessential
spending but there's one thing that made
the biggest dent in my spending moving
back to my parents house this was
actually a really tough decision and a
huge blow to my ego because i've been
living that independent woman life for
the past six years and i wasn't about to
move back to my mom's house but once i
set up my plan this was kind of a
no-brainer for me so the strategy here
is to ignore your parents for six years
and when you come back they're gonna be
so happy they're gonna be showering you
with love and food
joking now i know that i'm very very
fortunate to have this but where you
live is a major major contributor to
your income and your cost of living and
if i didn't have this i might have
actually moved to another city where the
cost of living was not so high i would
have definitely gotten a roommate the
second thing i was looking for was any
areas where i could increase my income
so the first thing that i did was
actually ask for a raise and
that didn't go very well
and so the next thing that i did was
looking for any freelance services i
could provide on the side the problem is
when you're an intern you don't have
that much experience but there are some
things that you are going to be good at
so this is when i sat down and made a
list of all my strengths to try to
figure out what my marketable strengths
were
after an exhaustive list i came up with
two skills rendering and photography so
i told everyone i knew if you know
anyone who needs renderings or
photography services i'm the one i can
do it cheap and well so i started
getting some rendering jobs here and
there i was starting to meet my monthly
financial goals but i was really working
around the clock because you know big
surprise i was charging too little for
my services till one day
all of that changed
[Music]
i have been working for a client who
owned a pastry franchise called stuffies
i actually met this client through my
boss at the time a quick tip here your
firm and your bosses are actually gonna
be your biggest untapped resource for
finding your side income when you're an
architect and especially when you have
your own firm
you get a lot of people asking you to do
work that's just too small and not
feasible for the firm to do like
renderings in my case
this was my boss's old client from the
days when he was an intern and
freelancing i took this on i did the
renderings but i also did any kind of
graphics or promotional banners and kind
of anything and everything and over time
i gained their trust uh so one day this
uh stuffy's client asked me if i could
do a design for their new store at the
eden center in toronto because they're a
franchise they already have all of their
design guidelines that talks about the
color font signage feel atmosphere so my
job was to just adopt it for the new
space and you know figure out the
circulation and make it functional it's
not the most interesting work for a
designer but once you do it once it's
relatively easy to do another and
another and another of course for
construction drawings you can charge a
lot more than just doing renderings in
bc for projects of a certain type up to
a certain size you actually don't need a
licensed architect as long as you have
another licensed professional like an
electrical or a mechanical engineer and
actually
this is like when you're an intern
is the perfect time for you to be doing
the small project because once you
become a licensed architect no matter
how small the project you need to sign
off on the drawings and you can't really
do that without a liability insurance or
a certificate of practice
which actually cost thousands of dollars
once you become a licensed architect
you're actually a lot more limited to
what you can and you can't do i have a
video where i talk about the pros and
cons of getting licensed i'll leave it
right here so anyways this kept
happening i would get hired to do one
thing like renderings or photography and
i get asked to do the design or
construction drawings as a young
graduate you might think that you don't
have the skills to make side income but
you actually do if you just keep your
ears open and tell everyone you know
that you're providing these services
and now you have things like fiverr or
upwork right just get into the habit of
showing off your work and your skills
and once you get the job
meet deadlines do amazing work be
responsive be nice and pleasant to work
with do such a good job
that when they need other design
services they're gonna be like oh wait
um can you do it
so this is a very quick breakdown of how
i paid off my student loans in two years
yes i was very fortunate to be able to
live rent free at my mom's and i was
lucky to work for bosses who would
regularly throw work my way but none of
this would have manifested in my life if
i hadn't made a concrete step-by-step
plan to pay off my loans of course i had
months where things didn't go as planned
but when you don't have a roadmap you're
just letting your loans control you when
you set a goal and track that goal and
do whatever it takes to meet that goal
you will start to see gaps and
opportunities that you hadn't seen
before
if you're an intern architect one of the
fastest ways you can increase your
salary is to get licensed and get more
letters after your name if you're
interested in learning about how i got
licensed in less than four years of
working i'll leave the video right here
if you're not interested in that and you
just want to see some cool architecture
videos i have a video on my
architectural thesis i'll leave it right
here if you want to see more content
like this hit the subscribe button and
you'll get more content on career and
design and creativity if you want to get
notified next time i release a new video
you can hit the notification bell with
that i'll see you guys in the next video
[Music]
you